[Música]
no en pase entre colombia y venezuela
esta vez con la relación a la migración
venezolana a territorio colombiano y es
que el gobierno de nicolás maduro
denunciara ante la onu a colombia por
los asesinatos en tibú de los jóvenes
venezolanos detenidos cuando
supuestamente robaban en un comercio en
el norte de santander la vicepresidenta
de si rodríguez en su cuenta de
'twitter' señaló al presidente iván
duque es el responsable por lo que
considera el exterminio de venezolanos a
esto se suma un nuevo hecho de violencia
que dejó 5 muertos entre ellos tres
venezolanos este fin de semana este
ataque fue perpretado por hombres
armados en una finca en betania en el
departamento colombiano de antioquia
para ello quiero saludar en este momento
a julio chávez él es vicepresidente del
psv para los estados monagas y también
delta amacuro y además presidirá la
comisión para investigar estos
asesinatos de los venezolanos en el
extranjero gracias a julio por estar
aquí con nosotros en directo américa en
france 24 le pregunto primero para dar
un contexto no cómo se ven las cosas
desde venezuela en cuanto a la migración
venezolana sobre todo país que recibe la
mayor cantidad de población desplazada
bueno un gran saludo a todos ustedes
gracias por esta invitación y la
situación que se ha venido presentando
con el vecino país de colombia en los
últimos años ha venido complejizando se
está grabando en virtud de una cantidad
de agresiones que hemos recibido desde
el suelo colombiano desde el momento en
que se firma el plan colombia entre
colombia y eeuu
y en virtud de haber ganado en venezuela
en aquel entonces el comandante hugo
chávez se ha desatado toda una campaña
para en principio debilitar el signo
monetario para atacar la economía y
luego propiciar una situación de tensión
en la frontera colombo-venezolana es una
frontera muy extensa de casi 2000
kilómetros que compartimos con el vecino
país y en este momento de esta situación
que se ha venido agravando recordemos
las denuncias que se han formulado en
virtud de que en territorio colombiano
se han detectado se han denunciado con
coordenadas con pruebas georeferenciadas
la instalación de campamentos para
entrenar
irregulares en función de arremeter
contra contra venezuela no toda esta
situación que se ha agudizado en los
últimos años en virtudes que en colombia
existen nueve bases militares
norteamericanas presuntamente para
luchar contra el narcotráfico y el
terrorismo lo que ha ocurrido en los
últimos años que se ha incrementado en
la superficie cultivada de droga y ellos
requieren y necesitan
de venezuela como un tránsito para
llevar la droga por la fachada del
caribe no y en vista de que venezuela se
ha plantado firme no contra esa digamos
contra esa política del gobierno
colombiano no hemos permitido hemos
de importar una cantidad importante de
narcotraficante colombiano y esto ha
afectado un lucrativo negocio de más de
300 mil millones de dólares porque
recordemos que la mayor cantidad de
droga que produce colombia bueno la
consume la población norteamericana no
soy bueno toda esta situación se ha
venido agudizando y ha llegado al
extremo de que en colombia se han
cometido asesinatos
no contra migrantes venezolanos la
propia el propio informe forense la
medicatura de colombia registra más de 2
mil asesinatos en los últimos años
producto de la xenofobia
producto de esta campaña del intermedio
porque precisamente tocaba una palabra
exterminio como lo decía la
vicepresidenta venezolana de si
rodríguez que quiero preguntar si
realmente ustedes en el gobierno del
presidente nicolás maduro creen que se
están exterminando los venezolanos sobre
todo en colombia
mira lo que ha venido ocurriendo en los
últimos los últimos meses y con esta
situación que se presentó con el
asesinato de dos adolescentes que además
fueron grabados y expuestos un bueno al
escarnio público que habla y da cuenta
de una política de estado que ha
desarrollado colombia en virtud de la
campaña de odio de la campaña xenófoba
cuando en principio ellos llamaron a que
la gente abandonara venezuela que se
fuera del país recordemos que se
quedaron ong del lado colombiano que han
recibido millones de dólares para
presuntamente atender esta migración
de venezolanos por razones económicas
hacia colombia otros países y toda esta
operación que es organizado porque es
una organización delincuencial han
estado auspiciada por el gobierno de
duke y por el propio gobierno del
presidente piñera de chileno ahora julio
también hay contrastes porque la
comunidad internacional también ha
bloqueado al ejecutivo colombiano a la
cabeza del presidente
iván duque por este estatuto de
protección a migratorio a los millones
de venezolanos que se encuentran en
venezuela como usted ve esto
bueno es parte de eso digamos de esa de
esa posición
inmovilista del gobierno del presidente
duque porque no solamente es que asesinó
a dos migrantes venezolanos es muy grave
para nosotros no mediante la cantidad de
dirigentes sociales de colombia que
todos los días son asesinados el
producto de la acción del esmad y la
política de estado colombiana de modo
que creo que eso se contradice con lo
que ocurre en la en el hecho concreto en
la realidad
nosotros hemos instalado una comisión
especial el parlamento venezolano que va
a recopilar todas estas denuncias más de
2.300 violaciones a digamos por
venezolanos migrantes en colombia
esta cantidad importante de asesinatos
que ha reportado inclusive el informe
forense a la medicatura de colombia está
el organismo que se han creado y que dan
cuenta
evidencia de que en efecto hay una
política de exterminio una política de
estado para arremeter contra la
migración venezolana toda vez que ellos
en principio
alentaron y por eso que la comisión va a
investigar y vamos a llevar esta
denuncia ante la corte penal
internacional para denunciar al
presidente duque por haber incurrido en
delitos de lesa humanidad de exterminio
de asesinato inmigrante venezolano en
territorio colombiano julio muy
brevemente me quedan ya máximo 30
segundos 30 segundos para terminar esta
entrevista ya quiero preguntar qué
esperan con esta demanda ante la corte
penal internacional también la onu
pero denunciar esta situación que se
estaba gestando desde colombia es una
violación flagrante del derecho
internacional
de toda la edad de la normativa en
materia de derechos humanos pero que es
importante que la opinión pública del
mundo entero sepa lo que está ocurriendo
en colombia cómo se utiliza el
territorio para agredir a otros pueblos
de la región solo por proteger los
intereses de los eeuu norteamérica el
lucrativo negocio del narcotráfico que
es alentado por el estado colombiano en
que estas cosas hay que decírselos al
mundo entero de lo que está ocurriendo
en colombia y vamos a llevar esto hasta
las instancias sinti laterales para que
el presidente duque responda por delitos
por asesinatos por crímenes de
exterminio y sobre todo de violencia y
de violación sistemática derechos
humanos contra migrantes venezolanos
pero que también ocurre a lo interno del
territorio colombiano